This video is sponsored by LegalZoom.
More about LegalZoom at the end of the video.
Hey Wisecrack, Jared again.
For 20 Years, the kids of South Park have
been skewering every sacred cow they can find.
And at Wisecrack, that's just the kind of
thing that gets us hot.
In its thirteenth season, South Park masterfully
merged two of its favorite targets for ridicule:
religion and consumerism.
And you all know what happens when we marry
God and money.
OK, sure.
But also a multilayered argument about personal
agency and the opaque nature of the economy.
Break open a bag of Cheesy Poofs for this
Wisecrack Edition of the Philosophy of South
Park's "Margaritaville."
Religion has long been a handy tool for explaining
the unexplainable.
It's through clever religious allegory, then,
that "Margaritaville" manages to tackle the
economic crash of 2008 and a mysterious system
that for many remains the unexplainable - the
economy.
When the all-powerful "Economy" leaves South
Park in tatters, everyone is quick to direct
blame somewhere -- including Wall Street and
-- But it's Randy's characteristically bizarre
perspective that builds a large following
across South Park.
Taking his cues from old-school Protestant
ethics.
Randy preaches the economy is a petty vengeful
diety that must be placated by worship.
Randy's position draws from the fearful punishment-oriented philosophies of the Old Testament.
And South Park steers straight into those
biblical parallels, right down to the flinging
of stones -- I mean squirrels -- by those
who pass judgement on the fallen.
In fact, Randy's persecution of Kyle mimics
the biblical role of the Pharisees.
The Pharisses were an influential group of
people who, in the New Testament, greeted
Jesus's message with skepticism, paranoia,
and ultimately, incitement of violence.
Kyle's third-act self-sacrifice in which he,
a Christ-like figure, has dinner with his
enemy, takes on all of South Park's debt,
and sacrafices himself for the community furthers
the biblical parallels that dominate the episode.
Kyle's sacrafice parallels the crucifixion
of Jesus, but where Jesus took on the sins
of the world.
Kyle shoulders the debt of all of South Park.
Just as Jesus's death was mourned by a weeping
Mary as he was taken from the Cross, Kyle's
figurative "death" is mourned here by his
own weeping mother.
Kyle has died.
Kyle is risen.
Kyle will come again.
Not unlike the hero of the New Testament,
Kyle sets forth a philosphy which challenges
and chastises the accepted norms of the community.
But whereas Jesus set forth a religious code
of conduct, Kyle sets forth a financial one.
His philosphy, known in the real world as
faith-based economics proposes "the economy"
is us -- and should be trusted, not feared.
Since people drive the economy, Kyle argues,
we are at one with economy.
Forever and ever.
Amen.
Margaritaville effectively positions the economy
as a modern religion unto itself.
Throughout the episode, Randy and Kyle's conflicting
arguments don't merely demonstrate religious
parallels, They spring from some interesting
econmonic and social theory.
For example, Randy's unforgiving message of
self-discpline and self-denial maps well with
the ethics described by German sociologist
Max Weber in "The Protestant Ethic and The
Spirit of Capitalism".
For Weber, the Protestant values of austerity
and frugality were crucial components in the
development of modern capitalism.
In other words: work until you die, and don't
make any time for any fun.
While Randy preaches economic restraint, Kyle
offers a very different take one reflected
in the work of British economist John Maynard
Keynes who proposed consumer spending is what
truly keeps the economy humming.
If you want economic growth, Keynesian economics
argues, you've just gotta keep moving that
paper.
But, hey, if you didn't know much about these
two economic perspectives, South Park is not
surprised.
Because one of the big ideas tackled in this
episode is that economics are deliberately
made too difficult for most people to understand.
This strategy of linguistically keeping information
at arm's length from the everyday citizen
is known as technostrategic discourse and
it's so powerful and so dangerous, "Margaritaville"
dedicates an entire "B" storyline to demonstrating
it in action.
Take, for example, when Stan visits his bank
and is treated to a string of jargon before
his money magically disappears without explanation.
Of course, we all know economics isn't magic,
but most of us don't quite know the intricacies
of what economics are.
And, as the subprime mortgage crisis of the
late 2000s demonstrated, those who are in
the know are counting on, and even profiting
from, our ignorance.
Even if they themselves might be ignorant,
too.
French Philosopher and turtleneck enthusiast
Michel Foucault argued that, in our modern
era power was no longer concentrated but dispersed
through complex systems: prisions, religious
authorities, and as South Park highlights,
finance.
Unlike traditional conceptions of power, which
might imagine a bunch of bankers in smoke-filled
rooms conspiring to screw everyone over.
Foucault explored how individuals each played
their own tiny role in this system of power,
often ignorant to complete workings of the
system.
Power, dispersed in this way, shows up in
South Park as Stan climbs up the ladder of
helpless bureaucrats: each of them powerless
to the rules, or magic, of the system they
participate in.
In scene after scene, so-called experts sustain
and amplify power through the exploitation
of confusion.
Stan goes to return his Margaritaville at
Sur le Table, only for Stan to be shooed off
to the finance company.
The finance company points Stan to Wall St,
the people really running the show, only for
Stan to learn from Wall Street that it is
ultimately the treasury department who is
in charge.
The interesting piece here is that, Stan,
as he journeys into the world of finance to
find who is in charge finds out that no one
is really in charge.
As the very nature of money is an amorphous
abstraction, its source -- and, with it, a
source of power -- never seems to be anywhere.
Anyone who's turned to a lawyer, to a doctor,
or to a computer technician for support probably
knows the drill.
No matter how dense the language or how straightforward
the problem, you're simply expected to trust
in the experts.
But what's the result of this technocratic
babble?
According to South Park, the consumer is essentially
exhausted into submission, either willfully
throwing himself at the mercy of technocrats...or
uh, smashing dad's blender on the floor.
In matters both relgious and economic, "Margaritaville"
challenges the seemingly distant and unknowable
forces that govern our lives and fates.
If money isn't real, if the powerful deliberately
complicate things in order to retain their
power, and if the answers we seek don't necessarily
lie with the experts or with the divine...
whom does South Park suggest we blame in the
face of economic or spiritual misfortune?
Maybe the answer is found in the Jimmy Buffet
song "Margaritaville," in which a drunk man
sits in a bar and laments his failed relationship.
By the end of the tune, the man gradually
realizes his own drinking problem may have
contributed to his failure in love.
Personal responsibility.
It's a hell of a drug.
Bottoms up, Wisecrack.